alors il a aussi dit quelque chose
d'autre c'est pour vous montrer à quel
point on est honnête on n'a pas coupé
dans son interview j'en prends une
petite encore ah oui sauf que là par
contre c'est plus du tout la même
limonade parce que alors je sais pas
pourquoi mais c'est bien retouches sur
cette photo
quand même méchant dites ça je rigole il
est magnifique
pour qu'est-ce qui va pas avec lui
pourquoi ça colle je pense qu'il y a une
tension entre nous et une tension
sexuelle je pense qu'il faut peut-être
faire
à la fin elle a fait un truc et il
m'avait demandé si on pouvait aller
boire un verre je t'ai dit non ah bon
ouais
bravo alors là on a vraiment là on est
dans le mais je vous je crois je crois
que je n'ai d'abord merci pour il est
tapé merci beaucoup il est retapé
l'ancien Mathieu Delormeau qui n'était
pas gentil gagne tu aurais dit mais
c'est l'ancien tu aurais dit moi entre
temps entre deux interviews j'ai pas
pris 20 kg mais ça c'était l'ancien
c'était l'ancien le nouveau te dit
Nicolas c'est vrai je vieillis comme
tout le monde il est beau garçon
une fois sur un plateau télé je n'ai
jamais vu je crois que je ne l'ai jamais
vu de ma vie tu lui as proposé un verre
et il a dit non je ne l'ai jamais vu de
médecine
vous oubliez jamais vu de ma vie
tu crois que je propose des verres à des
gens qui n'ont plus rien qui ont tout
perdu je ne crois pas non
alors
[Applaudissements]
écoutez on va passer une heure dessus
qu'est-ce que vous voulez
avec beaucoup de plaisir dès que j'ai un
petit peu de temps